régine exerce le métier d'assistante
maternelle depuis 11 ans comme 800
autres de ses collègues dont cinq hommes
pour environ 1700 enfants placés la smat
comme on l'appelle communément accueil
accompagne et du que les enfants placés
dans sa famille
est assistante maternelle aujourd'hui
c'est accueillir des enfants à son
domicile
mais il faut savoir qu'il ya de
deux façons d instinct maternel
assistantes maternelles de jour là c'est
les parents qui confient leurs enfants à
l'assistante maternelle à la journée ou
alors comme moi c'est en maternelle
permanente
là on est employé par une institution
soit le conseil général ou un hôpital ou
une institution quelconque et là on nous
confie des enfants à temps plein c'est à
dire 24 heures sur 24 365 jours par an
est-ce qu'il faut un diplôme pour être
assistante maternelle n'ont pas de
diplôme actuellement mais il faut un
agrément cet agrément à
à la réunion c'est le département qui
nous le donne il faut faire une demande
il ya une équipe d'instruction qui vient
faire une enquête médecins psychologues
assistantes sociales il ya tout un
travail qui se fait pendant six mois et
au bout de six mois la commission
d'agrément donne son avis favorable ou
défavorable
et c'est le président qui signent
l'agrément pour l'instant de maternelle
et quels sont les critères justement
pour être assistante maternelle il n'y a
pas de critère vraiment il faut être
disponible bien sûr il faut
savoir se débrouiller avec les enfants
avoir un côté
éducatif le côté affectif
et puisse avoir mêlé le professionnelle
et la vie familiale et l'affectif et ça
c'est difficile
quand est-ce qu'on peut parler de
placement de chance alors on plaint on
parle de placement d'urgence quand
l'enfant arrive chez nous d'un on
appelle le soir ou le matin pour placer
l'enfant le soir mais là c'est toujours
dans le cadre de la protection de
l'enfant quand l'enfant est en danger le
service estime que l'enfant est en
danger donc on le place d'urgence chez
innocent maternelle et là le la stand
maternelle doit s'organiser justement
pour accueillir cet enfant tout de suite
et le protéger de la menace qu'il avait
là aussi le service soutient énormément
l'instant de maternelle parce que ben
arrive à recueillir un enfant comme ça
leurs enfin une heure pour une heure
après et c'est pas évident on n'a pas eu
le temps de se préparer on n'a pas eu le
temps de faire connaissance donc là
aussi le soutien du service est
important mais bien sûr le plus souvent
c'est quand l'enfant est en danger ou
alors quand les parents sont
hospitalisés ou alors des parents décède
malheureusement là aussi il ya eu des
cas tel est le cas le plus fréquent
je dirais pour maltraitance quand
l'enfant est en danger le plus souvent
c'est ça
pour votre vie familiale personnelle est
ce que pour vous ça a été un problème de
recevoir chez vous des enfants placés
par rapport à vos propres relations avec
votre ou vos enfants
non des départs ça n'a pas été un
problème parce qu'on en a 1 mûrement
réfléchi et je dirais même que je
voulais faire ce métier bien avant
d'avoir mes propres enfants
mon mari sa maman était assistante
maternelle donc il connaît ce que c'est
j'ai ma grand mère paternelle qui était
assistante maternelle toute sa vie une
grande tente qui était à sa maternelle
toute sa vie ma maman était assistante
maternelle pendant longtemps donc je
connaissais un petit peu ce qui était le
métier d'assistante maternelle et c'est
venu tout naturellement en discuter avec
mon mari on s'est dit voilà on va faire
d'abord nos propres enfants parce qu'on
en voulait 2 et puis après on verra et
après voilà j'ai choisi de faire cette
promesse profession il ya à peu près
onze ans comment vous arrivez à gérer
par rapport à vos propres sentiments que
vos enfants avoué les enfants passaient
alors là aussi je crois que l'expérience
y est pour beaucoup parce qu'au départ
j'arrivais pas justement à faire cette
balance entre mes enfants et des enfants
que j'accueillais des fois je me sentais
assistantes maternelles pour mes propres
enfants et mamans pour les enfants que
j'appuyais mais c'est bien sûr avec
blade de l'information j'ai eu entre
temps l'occasion de faire une formation
dead médico psychologique ce qui m'a
énormément aidé dans ma profession
actuellement et je crois que maintenant
même avec des difficultés au jour le
jour j arrive justement à faire cette
balance là et faire comprendre à mes
enfants et aux enfants placés la place
de chacun
ces enfants placés chez vous à ce qu'ils
s'intègrent bien en principe n'est pas
de problème chez moi je dirais oui
les six premiers mois ça a été un petit
peu difficile parce qu'il a fallu que
les deux j'accueille actuellement il
s'était placé en urgence n'y a pas eu de
préparation
donc moi je pense qu'il a fallu bien six
mois pour qu'il s'adapte à ma vie de
famille et depuis
dix ans maintenant qu'ils sont là ça se
passe plutôt bien je dirais par rapport
à d'autres collègues où j'ai vu des cas
où vraiment c'était vraiment difficile
et comment sont gérées des cas très
difficile
c'est gérer au cas par cas avec le
soutien de l'équipe bien sûr il ya
chaque assistant maternel est suivi par
un référent assistante sociale ou
éducatrice spécialisée
il ya un psychologue dans le service il
y à un responsable de but donc ce qui
fait que l'instinct maternel normalement
on ne devrait pas se retrouver tout seul
avec un cas difficile mais il faut aussi
qu'elles aillent
vers ce service est demandé de l'aide
demandée soutien demandé conseil à un
moment il faut bien qu'il y ait une
séparation est ce que c'est une
déchirure à ce que ça se passe bien dans
l'ensemble
oui et non aussi au cas par cas là aussi
parce que quand les enfants restent chez
nous quinze jours ou trois semaines ben
ça dépend des enfants là peut-être on a
eu moins le temps de s'y habituer de sa
tâche et ça se fait plus facilement mais
moi j'ai eu deux petites pendant deux
mois et demi et ça a été un déchirement
quand elles sont parties et pourtant
elles sont restées chez moi que deux
mois et demi d'autres cas les enfants
sont restés dix quinze ans mais le
départ était préparé depuis longtemps et
ça se fait bien donc c'est au cas par
cas
membre de plusieurs commissions conseil
de famille protection de l'enfance
régine est également trésorière de
l'association des assistantes
maternelles du nord une des neuf
associations regroupées au sein de la
fédération réunionnaise dont elle est
également première vice présidente à ce
titre elle a été amenée à revendiquer au
niveau national un statut toujours en
cours de validation
quand l'assistante maternelle 120 hors
de son pays qui c'est qui s'occupe des
enfants placés les marion général
et c'est pour ça je dirais aussi qu'on
dit bien famille d'accueil parce que le
mari est sollicité en permanence dans
cette fonction d'un stand maternelle et
ben là quand on part comme ça pour une
semaine ou trois quatre jours mais c'est
le mari qui prend le relais tout
naturellement peut dire que vous êtes
deux fois maman
non je dirais pas deux fois maman je
fais
je difficile à dire je suis maman pour
mes propres enfants pour les enfants que
j'accueille je dirais je les accompagne
un bout de chemin je dirais plus ça
qu'être leur maman je ne peux pas et
leur maman et puis je serai maman de
plein d'enfants puisque on en accueille
tout le temps donc je dirais pas que je
suis leur maman ou je remplace leur
maman c'est pas possible je suis une
professionnelle qui les accompagnent
pendant un bout de leur vie voilà
votre femme je dirais
il faut se bouger
il faut prendre ses responsabilités
parce que si on ne prend pas nos
responsabilités aujourd'hui les maires
actuels de l'île de la réunion je crois
que notre société est elle fout l'camp
donc il faut prendre à bras le corps nos
enfants pour les éduquer comme il le
faut pour que demain on est une société
encore agréable dans laquelle on
aimerait vivre donc c'est à nous femmes
je dirais de ma génération de prendre en
charge les petits actuellement pour que
demain nos enfants soient de bons
parents
mon